[Musica]
ho avuto l'onore di essere invitato a
questo evento per parlare di desiderio e
della mia versione e visione
disintermediata in ambito sanitario il
desiderio in una delle sue tante
accezioni e può essere rappresentato dal
libero e universale accesso alle alle
cure
proprio in quest'ottica nel 2021 assieme
a tre amici abbiamo lanciato una
piattaforma web
denominata e ticker che consente di
donare prestazioni sanitarie
utilizzando la tecnologia bruxelles la
tecnologia blue chain è una struttura di
dati condivisa e immutabili che consente
di disintermediare tutti i processi
decisionali
restituendo di fatto alle persone il
controllo sulle proprie decisioni
proprio in quest'ottica e ticker
ridefinisce lo smart contract delle
donazioni
prevedendo la presenza di tre attori il
donatore
il paziente e l'erogatore della
prestazione sanitaria le potenzialità di
di kerr sono inespresse ad oggi vi
consiglio di andare a cercare sul web e
di comprenderne e facilmente quelle che
sono le potenzialità
applicabili per altro in vari campi
delle donazioni
però c'è un però ho pensato di
utilizzare questo spazio per parlare di
un qualcosa che da sette anni ha
radicalmente cambiato la mia vita e
quella anche di mia moglie perché voglio
parlare del desiderio di avere un figlio
quello che avete visto è un video che
avrei potuto conservare per sempre
mostrare a tutti invece il video che
testimonia l'ennesima delusione nel
lungo e faticoso percorso della ricerca
di un figlio sono stati sette anni con
momenti molto difficili in cui per
fortuna la bussola è stata ferma verso
l'obiettivo ed ogni delusione era un
momento di crescita della coppia in
sette anni ho imparato
nuovi acronimi feedback pma blastocisti
in sette anni ho veramente toccato con
le mani quelli che sono quelle che sono
le difficoltà in questo percorso
il desiderio di un figlio non può essere
ovviamente bloccato o cancellato con un
click e quindi ogni donna in attesa ogni
passeggino era un momento di riflessione
ma anche di dolore il processo della
procreazione medicalmente assistita è
molto faticoso e duro soprattutto per la
donna che viene sottoposta a trattamenti
ormonali a siringhe nella pancia a
trattamenti invasivi che ne vanno a
minare la
fisicità ma anche ovviamente la sua
sfera emotiva l'uomo in questo processo
fa ben poco perché il suo è il supporto
soltanto logistico è ovviamente motivo
in questi anni ho
imparato a
capire che la scienza ad un certo punto
si ferma nel momento in cui la
blastocisti questo è uno dei termini che
ho imparato in questi anni viene
incantate nell'utero
la scienza non riesce più a spiegare il
motivo del suo eventuale ho mancato
attecchimento all'utero
partendo da questo puoi mangiarti la
testa puoi decidere di girare le
cliniche di mezzo mondo
puoi cercare la verità in varie forme
però poi anche decidere di investire
tutto quello che hai nel nella ricerca
di un figlio perché tutti questi
trattamenti sono trattamenti a pagamento
perché il servizio sanitario nazionale
consente di fare la procreazione
medicalmente assistita
però quello che la differenza il
pubblico dal privato e ovviamente la
presenza di laboratori tecnologicamente
più avanzati nel privato e trattandosi
di trattamenti invasivi è meglio
affidarsi a laboratori più avanzati
rispetto a quindi al pubblico
poi un giorno decide che è giusto e
arrivato il momento di pensare in
maniera differente perché dietro al ogni
desiderio inesaudito c'è anche tanta
sofferenza
ma c'è anche la speranza
una sera infatti proprio quella del
video mostrato in precedenza con mia
moglie ci siamo guardati negli occhi e
abbiamo deciso che il tempo era maturo
per
rinunciare all'idea di avere un figlio
biologico
proprio con la stessa sera abbiamo
deciso di intraprendere un nuovo
percorso
il percorso che ci avrebbe portato ad
adottare un figlio
questo percorso deve iniziare da
un'inversione del paradigma
naturale cioè è necessario pensare che
l'adozione non è uno strumento per
soddisfare una mancanza della coppia ma
l'adozione è uno strumento che consente
di donare felicità e amore a un bambino
che magari è a 10 mila chilometri di
distanza
l'adozione però è uno strumento appunto
perché la legislazione di riferimento è
dell 83 rivista nel 2002
nel modulo di adozione sono presenti dei
campi che tiri chi è che richiedono la
volontà o meno di adottare un bambino di
colore oppure ci chiedono di
adottare se vuoi o meno adottare un
bambino figlio di genitori
tossicodipendenti e con una patologia
psichiatrica
questo modulo assieme a tanti altri sono
dei moduli che vengono compilati in fase
di presentazione della domanda al
tribunale dei minori dopo aver compilato
questi moduli e consegnati oa mano a
questi moduli viene fatto un colloquio
con il giudice in quello che conoscitivo
questi questo qui è il primo step che
consente la verifica di quelli che sono
il possesso dei requisiti
giuridici della coppia il secondo step è
quello che viene fatto presso il
consultorio del comune di
di appartenenza
in questa questa fase qui vengono
verificati da presenza del dei requisiti
morali della coppia perché c'è
l'assistente sociale e lo psicologo
terminato quest altro step inizia il
momento della dell'incertezza sui tempi
perché in una città medio grande i tempi
possono essere più lunghi perché gli
assistenti sociali devono fare una
relazione e le comunicazioni con le
coppie sono molte volte molte volte
formali tramite lettere tramite
raccomandata addirittura quelle verdi
quelle delle multe è andata
relativamente bene perché in otto anni
in otto mesi scusate abbiamo ricevuto il
decreto d'idoneità all'adozione
nazionale internazionale e adesso siamo
nuovamente in attesa in attesa di che
cosa siamo in attesa che il giudice ci
chiami e ci proponga un bambino in
affido per quanto riguarda l'adozione
nazionale oppure siamo in attesa di
rivolgersi e o di affidarci a
un'associazione che rappresenta il paese
in cui vogliamo adottare il bambino
questo perciò un percorso di quella
dell'adozione internazionale prevede la
che la coppia sia lì nel paese per 40 45
giorni prevede l'esborso di circa 40 45
mila euro
un'altra cosa importante dell'adozione
questa che se uno della coppia avuto nei
cinque anni precedenti alla data di
presentazione della domanda una
patologia di salute seria non è
possibile adottare un bambino
su questo mondo credo che sia giunto il
momento
di fare chiarezza di cercare di scuotere
gli animi perché se da un lato la
burocrazia deve garantire il possesso
dei requisiti giuridici della coppia è
anche vero che è la burocrazia crei la
crea una barriera tra il desiderio di
amore di un bambino e il desiderio di
felicità di una coppia
è arrivato il momento credo di superare
queste barriere insieme come beh
iniziando in primo luogo a definire
tempi certi e regole chiare che
definiscano i criteri di ammissibilità
delle coppie è necessario aprire a
livello nazionale un confronto che
coinvolga gli attori di questo processo
le coppie i centri e o le comunità
presso cui sono collocati i bambini è il
tribunale dei minori
definire delle regole
consentirebbe di definire anche dei
tempi certi perché il silenzio assenso
potrebbe essere utilizzato come criterio
base per ricevere o meno idonei età a
ricevere il bambino disunita per avere
per adottare un bambino
l'utilizzo della tecnologia potrebbe
facilitare tantissimo questo processo
addirittura come abbiamo fatto per e
ticker si potrebbe applicare la
tecnologia blog chain anche in questo
ambito come andranno a definire un nuovo
smart contract che preveda la presenza
di tre attori fondamentali in questo
processo il bambino ok la coppia lo
stato rappresentato ovviamente dal
tribunale dei minori questo
consentirebbe di disintermediare
completamente il processo e di renderlo
più agevole e pur vero che non ho una
soluzione a questo problema
perché non è facile individuare questa
soluzione
molte volte il buon senso una parola
data con detta con amore un messaggio
whatsapp da parte di un assistente
sociale possono cambiare la vita di una
coppia che attende da anni
da mesi ma anche da giorni un bambino
nella propria nella propria vita si
potrebbe guardare alla legislazione di
paesi in cui l'adozione funziona per
esempio e importare quel modello in
italia ci vuole uno sforzo comune da
parte di tutti perché non è più
possibile che questo tema sia
nascosto e non se ne parli più
in questo percorso poi può capitare che
ti propongono un bambino in figlio
temporaneo la parola temporaneo è
ovviamente
legato a
al termine fugace nel momento in cui ti
fanno questa proposta inizia a pensare
ma come mi chiamerà il bambino come il
fatto come faccio a spiegare a un mio
parente o a mio amico che questo bambino
c'è e domani potrà non esserci
quanto durerà l'affido
questo qui è un tema
che abbiamo affrontato nei vari incontri
con gli assistenti sociali e proprio in
questi incontri durante questi incontri
abbiamo avuto l'onore di incontrare un
papa che aveva in affido temporaneo una
bambina che ci ha detto questo ci ha
detto
voi date da te amore e tutto quello che
da te vi ritornerà mi piace concludere
il mio intervento con una
case di roberto saviano che in grado di
tradurre al meglio quello che il mio
pensiero
trasformare qualsiasi cosa
l'impossibilità di felicità
questo è quello che fanno i bambini
grazie
[Applauso]